[Music]
on this monday night the investigation
into letters
tainted with a toxin the poisonous
envelope mailed to the u.s
president sends police to a quebec home
the other letters intercepted too and
the woman
arrested growing frustration with kobit
19
rule breakers send you to the mri to get
your brain scanned because i just i
don't think there's anything in there
big spikes in canada's biggest provinces
a lucky stick another pandemic election
the next province going to the polls and
why it's a political gamble
and the emmys were full of shit's creek
what is your favorite season awards
the canadian sitcom making history oh my
god ew david
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with developments in the case
of letters laced with poison
sent to several u.s locations including
to the american president
a quebec woman has been arrested and is
in custody in buffalo new york
and today police raided a condo near
montreal assisted
by a specialized team trained to deal
with chemical and biological threats
rcmp say there is a link between this
raid and the suspect
arrested in buffalo it is working with
the fbi
on the investigation it began after a
suspicious letter containing the highly
toxic substance
ricin was intercepted at a government
mail facility
it was addressed to president trump it's
emerged there were other letters too
including some sent to a sheriff and his
staff in texas
there's lots to cover on this story we
have two reports tonight beginning with
abigail beeman
and the raid that took place in quebec
rcmp officers with specialized gear move
into an apartment building in the
montreal suburb of st to bear
some neighbors watch from balconies
those closest to the unit where the
search warrant is executed were told to
leave
because of the nature of the substance
either would it be ricin or another
highly toxic substance
we decided to take all precautions ricin
a poison derived from castor beans
an amount the size of a pinhead can
cause death
there's no antidote it was found inside
letters addressed to the white house
as well as law enforcement and detention
facilities in south texas
a female suspect was arrested last night
as she was attempting to cross from the
canada
into the united states sources say she
had a gun
rcmp are assisting the fbi and say that
suspect is
linked to this quebec apartment but
aren't saying much more
beyond targeting the president of the
united states the motive
isn't clear the biggest thing for me in
terms of next steps for this case
will be in terms of what the rcmp tell
us about whether or not there are
ongoing investigations in canada
so basically what this means is whether
or not there are other individuals they
suspect to be involved
as of now the only suspect named in this
case is in custody awaiting a court
appearance in buffalo new york
tuesday it's not clear what charges she
faces
abigail beeman global news ottawa
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson has been working her
sources mercedes the rcmp are leading
the investigation
here in canada what have you learned
well donna we now have the name of the
suspect who is accused of having sent
these ricin
laced letters to the united states
including the white house her name
is pascal ferriere she was as
you just heard picked up trying to enter
the united states sources say
with a gun pascal farrier again the
woman who sent these letters according
to law enforcement and intelligence
sources
now in terms of what we know about the
investigation at this point
we do know it is ongoing and is being
taken very seriously by canadian
authorities
we saw part of that manifest today with
who was actually
on the ground to carry out the search in
that apartment building
normally this would just be the police
but today the military showed up
and not just anyone in the military
donna a highly
specialized and very secretive unit from
the canadian special operations command
they're known as c jairu the canadian
joint incident response group
and not only are they highly trained and
deadly operators
they're also experts in nuclear
biological and chemical devices
the fact that they were there today is
the first time we've seen them
operate publicly in canada and it goes
to tell you just how concerned
authorities were
about what they might find inside that
apartment
and mercedes we know there was more than
one letter do we know if investigators
are looking for multiple people
donna there are certainly people who
investigators would like to speak to
in particular one source with direct
knowledge of the investigation tells me
there is a mail that police are
interested in speaking to
it's not entirely clear what the
relationship is there or why
but one of the standard things that
investigations look at at this point is
did somebody have help did they act
alone
how did she learn how to refine ricin
and make it successfully without
killing herself or somebody else and
where did the money and motive come from
some of this might be revealed in the
court documents tomorrow so we're
certainly anxiously awaiting that
but in the meantime i can tell you that
a source says there have been cell phone
intercepts and there have been
conversation intercepts
that have led the police to be
interested in about 13 people
who may be connected in some way they're
looking into that
and donna i'm also told that the amount
of ricin in that envelope was not small
it was substantial and that's what's led
to some of this concern
all right mercedes stevenson thanks now
to covet 19 after weeks of rising case
numbers in some regions of canada today
there was another spike
multiple provinces are reporting the
highest number of daily new cases in
months
there are 128 cases reported in bc
137 cases in alberta in ontario 425
people tested positive that's
the biggest one day jump since early
june and in quebec the daily case number
is even higher
586 positive tests today
quebec's top doctor says he now believes
that province is at the beginning of a
second wave
and he's pleading with people to do
everything possible in the next couple
of weeks
to reverse it mike armstrong reports
police forces across quebec fanned out
over the weekend
hitting more than 2 200 bars and
restaurants
well they don't appear to have had much
trouble finding people breaking covet 19
safety protocols
they handed out about 1500 warnings and
90 tickets the offenses things like not
keeping a registry of patrons
or people drinking while standing the
province is considering another police
operation next weekend
the public health director says monday's
numbers close to
600 new cases show what's being done
so far isn't working we haven't lost
control
but there is a very preoccupating
situation
the rules are tightening in three
regions of quebec the alert level was
raised to orange as of 1201
monday morning in those regions
including montreal
alcohol can't be sold after 11 pm bars
have to close at midnight
and private gatherings can't be more
than six people
montreal's public health director says
there haven't been any major
outbreaks but lots of small ones enough
that there's a consensus building
quebec is now in a second wave the fear
is big daily increases could turn
into exponential jumps i will tell you
things can go very fast one
struggle right now is contact tracing
too few people are cooperating
in montreal tracers called more than 500
people over the weekend
and only about a third answered or
called back
now two more high schools have major
testing operations underway both have
had about 20 cases each
teachers and students meantime there is
strain
on the testing system quebec is asking
the public
not to go for tests unless they have
symptoms have been in contact with
someone who tested positive
or if they've been asked to be tested by
health authorities
mike armstrong global news montreal
in ontario officials are promising to
release an action plan
imminently to help tackle spiking case
numbers and the surge in demand for
testing
of the 425 new infections today the vast
majority
were in toronto peel region and ottawa
and 67 percent of today's cases were
people who are under the age of 40.
premier doug ford doesn't mince his
words when talking about people who
break public health rules on public
gatherings
there are strict limits in place and
today his frustration
was targeted at the people who organized
a car show
on saturday in hamilton hundreds of
people attended
i don't get it i just don't get it if we
weren't so
backlogged on mris i'd send you to the
mri to get your brain scanned because i
just i don't think there's anything in
there
we get the protocols out there and
and they just blatantly ignore the
people
in alberta public health authorities are
trying to contain an outbreak that is
spreading through the province's largest
hospital 14 patients and four staff
members at calgary's foothills medical
center have tested positive
one patient who contracted the virus has
died multiple units inside the hospital
are affected
and 57 staff members are now in
isolation
british columbia will be the second
province to hold an election in the
middle of the pandemic
premier john horgan has called a snap
election for october 24th
horrigan whose ndp won a minority in the
last election
did sign an agreement with the green
party that he wouldn't hold an early
election that
is out the window now horgan says the
pandemic
changes everything he's hoping to win a
majority
rbc correspondent robin gill joins me
tonight robin
donna premier john horgan had to justify
calling this election on two fronts
first there's the pandemic
and he's concerned that it's going to go
for a longer period and that there will
be a recession
so the ndp government wants to ensure
that it gets a secure mandate for the
next four years
to start a recovery plan we are not at
the end
of cobit 19 we're at the beginning this
pandemic will be with us for a year or
more
and that's why i believe we need to have
an election now
we can either delay that decision and
create uncertainty
and instability over the next 12 months
more speculation
more talk about what might be or we can
do what i believe is always the right
thing
and ask british columbians what they
think
the other issue is that this is an ndp
minority government for the past
three and a half years the green party
has essentially propped it up
and the coalition agreed that there
would be no early election call that is
obviously now a broken promise
but that deal was cut with andrew weaver
who has since left the greens
premier horrigan admits that his
government isn't as strong as it was
before
seven cabinet ministers aren't running
again and this could very much be a
gamble donna
all right robin gill in bc tonight
thanks atlantic canada is bracing for
some severe weather as hurricane
teddy closes in advisories have been
issued for almost all of mainland nova
scotia as well as cape breton pei
and parts of newfoundland and labrador
the category one hurricane is expected
to transition to an intense
post-tropical storm as it approaches
forecasters say heavy rain and pounding
surf will begin on tuesday night
it's expected to make landfall wednesday
morning
a looming showdown at the u.s supreme
court coming up the battle brewing to
replace ruth bader ginsburg
place mission accomplished how canada's
indigenous communities crushed the
covid19 curve
and they were you picked up by the south
korean secret police on new year's
a little canadian shows big wins at the
emmys
the late u.s supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg will
lie in state in the u.s capitol on
friday the first woman to be honored
that way
right after she died the controversy
started swirling over whether her
replacement
replacement should be named before or
after the november 3rd presidential
election
ginsburg's granddaughter says her
deathbed wish was that she
not be replaced until the next president
is elected
but president trump isn't prepared to
wait he says he'll name a nominee on
friday or saturday
jackson proskow explains what's at stake
outside the supreme court they mourned
the loss of a liberal icon
and prepared to fight over filling the
vacant seat of justice ruth bader
ginsburg
five women are being looked at and
vetted very carefully defying ginsburg's
dying wish
president donald trump is prepared to
name a replacement before
november's election i'd much rather have
a vote
before the election because there's a
lot of work to be done
it's likely to be a woman all but
certainly a staunch conservative
someone like amy coney barrett a
pro-life judge with a traditional view
of the constitution
ginsburg's polar opposite for
generations we will see a solidly
a conservative court on issues of social
justice
the stakes couldn't be higher with the
court soon to weigh in on everything
from abortion to obamacare
perhaps even the election trump and
senate republicans still have to explain
why they should make a lifetime
appointment just 43 days before the
election
i expect everyone in the supreme court
thinks that that would be a mistake
the presidents have suggested in the
past that
americans should wait to find out what's
going to happen in the election
four years ago that was standard
republican thinking i am grateful beyond
words
the party blocked barack obama from
filling a vacant seat
nine months before the 2016 election
there is a long tradition
that you don't do this in an election
year that was then this
is now so the president was elected to
do this and the senate was elected
to confirm this nomination at least two
republican senators are uncomfortable
with the potential hypocrisy
and say they'll oppose a vote two more
and any nomination would be in jeopardy
while americans wait for trump to name a
nominee ginsburg will lie
in repose outside the u.s supreme court
so that the public can honor her legacy
and reflect on the future of the
institution donna
all right jackson in washington thanks
the u.s justice department has
designated three cities as what it calls
anarchist jurisdictions new york city
portland and seattle
the office of the attorney general
claims the cities have permitted
violence and destruction of property to
persist and have refused to undertake
reasonable measures to counteract
criminal activities president trump
issued a memo
earlier this month directing the doj to
identify jurisdictions that in its view
were not enforcing a law appropriately
those cities could lose their federal
funding
the mayors of new york portland and
seattle blasted back at trump today
calling it political and
unconstitutional and accusing the
president of playing cheap political
games
still ahead how canada's indigenous
communities are staying ahead of the
pandemic
you're watching global national
[Music]
since the start of the pandemic we all
have had to change our lives to slow the
spread of covid19
and the efforts of people in canada's
indigenous communities have emerged as a
standout success story
it was initially feared they'd be among
the most vulnerable to the virus
but indigenous communities have done
remarkably well keeping kovid 19 at bay
as heather urex west explains on the six
sick nation east of calgary there is a
new normal under covid19
members are screened tested and educated
about the virus
with their specific needs in mind if it
seeks a guy we might have
10 or so in a household so because of
the dynamics that's why we kind of test
more that's why we
contract contact trace more people
more than 5 000 tests have been done in
the community of just 4 000 people
there was an outbreak over the summer
but cases were kept to a minimum
just 31 and no deaths thanks in part to
the nation's extensive
emergency plan trailers that were built
for the 2013 floods as temporary
neighborhoods
for the flood affected six nation
members
we renovated 19 of them in a way that
if a family need to be isolated the
leadership on this reserve
knew that if coveted 19 was able to take
hold
the consequences could be devastating it
wasn't long ago that the h1n1 pandemic
hit indigenous communities hard those
stories
were the impact was
traumatizing um you know we had
communities in northern manitoba that
were not having supply center they were
having body bags sent
because indigenous communities have
higher rates of chronic illness and
often lack
access to services local leaders had to
make decisive moves
fast and that according to a new paper
published in the canadian medical
association journal
may have made all the difference travel
into indigenous communities was
restricted
and young indigenous influencers were
tapped to spread the message
only you and i can protect our future
the result was a first wave where
indigenous communities came out
relatively unscathed
a success to celebrate but not to rest
on
as communities like six sikka await a
possible
second wave heather your express global
news on the sixsick nation
up next shit's sweep the canadian show
that dominated tv's biggest night
what started as a little canadian show
made history last night
shit's creek won emmy awards in all
seven of the categories it was nominated
in
it's the first time a canadian show has
won best comedy series
the first time a series has won all four
acting categories
and the first time a series has swept
every comedy category
this is how emmy awards host jimmy
kimmel summed it up
shits creek won seven of them
unfortunately oh they fell
just short this is a killer if they'd
won
one more emmy they would have been able
to trade them in
for this a stanley cup
but they didn't so we're going to keep
it here for another 27 years
sorry canada no apology necessary mike
draulie explains why a canadian show
took the emmys
by storm eugene levy shits creek
imagine the script a pandemic award show
from hollywood where the first seven
awards are accepted
in toronto and the historic run of emmys
are handed out by someone
in a tuxedo hazmat suit it all seems so
shit's creek and again comedians
couldn't ask for a better circumstance
these people
are are designed for weird reaction
shots
and they um that was
that was weird oh we did great john the
show is an
overnight hit that's actually six years
old the brainchild of dan levy and his
father
comedic legend eugene levy about a
clueless family who's fallen on hard
times eugene levy summed its appeal
into a celebration of inclusivity a
castigation of homophobia
and a declaration of the power of loves
what is your favorite season
awards shit's creek developed a
worldwide following but that may never
have happened if not for the use of
gifts to market the show people would
see those funny clips and become
intrigued about where they came from
yes i think honestly shit's creek was a
social media success
because it spread like wildfire through
twitter
i'm a perfectly good driver i would
argue that i'm a better driver and my
license is suspended
another smart move the show never
claimed a nationality
all it was was the town of shits creek
which in real life is tiny goodwood
ontario
which has become something of a fan
destination it's
good it's bringing a lot of people to
the area goodwood's actually becoming
known
even though now we're becoming known for
shit's creek or the name they're calling
us shit's creek
and while that might normally cause
vexation a comedic sweep at the emmys is
giving anyone associated with the show
reason to smile mike drolie global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen one more honor
for shit's creek tonight's your canada
is the rosebud motel where exteriors of
the show were filmed in
orangeville ontario north of toronto and
about an hour away the community of
goodwood served as the backdrop for the
show
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]